[Music]
on this monday night
growing fears of that fast spreading
coronavirus variant
the criticism the feds are acting too
slowly this virus knows no borders
as ontario changes its policy on
reserving vaccine doses
the demands for tougher action at
airports rapid testing should be rolled
out at every international airport
across the country
as anxiety flies higher saudi arabia
sentences
a woman's rights activist to prison but
they consider women's rights activism
to be an act of terrorism the campaign
for her release
and her connection to canada plus the
commitment
and courage of essential workers you're
making a real difference
a salute to the pandemic's unsung heroes
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening to you
and your family thank you for being with
us on a date when canada's coveted 19
death toll topped 15 000 people
there are now growing concerns about the
arrival of a more
contagious variant of the virus canada
has at least five confirmed cases off
the variant
alberta reported a case just this
afternoon
all have some connection to travel to
the united kingdom
where the variant was discovered earlier
this month
the federal government now facing calls
to increase screening
to further limit non-essential
international travel
and to speed up the vaccine rollout
which was largely
halted over the holiday weekend oxford
university is tracking the number of
vaccine doses administered worldwide
as of sunday canada had administered
about 52
000 doses that's fewer per capita
than israel bahrain the uk
and the u.s while parts of this country
are still waiting to receive their first
vaccine shipments
global news has learned canada's biggest
province says
it's changing its policy and no longer
going to reserve doses for second shots
here's abigail beeman with no
readily available national vaccination
picture the kovid 19 canada open data
working group
built its own quebec for example has has
rolled out the vaccine in
just about every part of the province if
not every part of the province
but ontario is being criticized for
cutting capacity over the holidays
concern heightened with cases of the new
uk variant now in canada
it's not good optics to have to have
these clinics
shut down for you know a number of days
when we're being asked to you know keep
making
significant sacrifices ontario says the
pandemic exacerbated staffing challenges
and it was hospitals that asked for an
amended schedule but the health
minister's office tells global news they
expect to get all their initial 90
000 pfizer doses into arms in the next
several days
and in a change to their initial policy
they will no longer reserve
second doses meanwhile the federal
health minister's office tells global
news moderna vaccines are arriving in
the northwest territories and yukon
monday 200 doses each the rest of the
first 168 000 doses will roll out to
provinces and territories
this week i think they have been moving
too slowly and
you know this virus knows no borders it
knows no jurisdictions it knows no
holiday time
federal opposition parties are calling
for more data around both vaccines and
genome sequencing to find variants
i don't understand why canada isn't able
to
vaccinate at the same rate as countries
like israel or
you know the united states other other
countries around the world i think are
ahead of us on that
um and really the federal government
needs to explain why really
roll out the vaccine or vaccines now
actually
as quickly as possible president of
global research group cfar and a member
of the federal government's vaccine task
force
dr alan bernstein says we should be
doing several things in the face of the
new variant
and be prepared for other variants
including ones that develop here in
canada
we need to do a lot more dna sequencing
we need to understand
if there are new variants what their
properties are
we need to up our game on contact
tracing the liberals are defending their
vaccine plan
the health minister's office telling
global news their quote approach is
delivering putting the onus on the
provinces to get them out as fast as
possible
but offering few details about how many
doses are going to them
and when pharah abigail beeman in ottawa
thanks abigail
canada's restrictions on flights from
the united kingdom to limit the spread
of this new variant
are going to be in place until at least
sunday ontario premier doug ford
called for the federal government to
begin testing
incoming passengers for covet 19 at
canada's busiest airport
threatening to go at it alone if
necessary
but one week later there's no sign of
any change in procedures at toronto
pearson international airport
but ashan o'shea reports an airline
union says the time for action
has come sean
far it's been a week since the premier
of ontario demanded that the federal
government start testing arriving
international passengers for coronavirus
here at toronto pearson airport but that
hasn't happened yet
but one airline union says it should end
soon
at canada's busiest airport it's been a
week since ontario's premier declared
this
our borders are like a sieve like a
spaghetti drainer
no they aren't getting checked premier
doug ford claimed that cases of covet 19
are not getting detected because
incoming passengers are not tested when
they arrive stop the leak it doesn't
matter if there's 10 people getting
through
that's 10 too many that are going to be
out in the community
spreading spreading covet now one
airline union says the time for rapid
testing is overdue
rapid testing should be rolled out at
every international airport across the
country
sun wing pilot and union president
barrett armand points to calgary
international airport which brought in
testing almost two months ago
instead of a 14-day quarantine the
isolation period in calgary can be as
little as two days
although travelers must remain in the
province for two weeks
it's huge the the industry could
actually resume which i believe is what
the federal government wanted the
airline industry believes testing would
make travelers more confident about
taking a trip
but that's something governments have
discouraged during lockdowns
people are still traveling and as long
as people travel there's a need for
rapid testing
the union wants ford to follow through
on a promise to test
a provincial government spokesperson
told global news it's urging the federal
government
to urgently partner on testing or else
the ontario government
is prepared to act on its own if they
want to
help us well we'll do we'll be doing
ride checks on the side of the road as
people
exit because we're not putting people at
risk here at ontario the federal
government maintains that only about 1.3
percent of all
known coronavirus cases in ontario
originated with travel outside the
country
as for when testing will begin neither
government is saying
pharah shana pearson international
airport thank you sean
now canada is one of several countries
restricting travel to the united kingdom
which just recorded more than 40 000 new
cases
it is the biggest single day increase of
the pandemic there
the highest infection rates there are in
and around the london area where the
majority of these new cases are believed
to be caused
by the more infectious new variant of
the novel coronavirus
as redmond shannon reports that's
putting further strain
on the health care system there verbier
switzerland
popular with affluent british tourists
including the likes of prince william
but when scientists said the new uk
variant of the virus may be more
infectious
swiss authorities imposed a 10-day
quarantine on skiers who arrived from
the uk
reports that 200 of them escaped
quarantine caused
understandable outrage there are many
indicators that show that this number is
totally wrong
the first one is that we have statement
from the police that
all the controls they have done were
done
with satisfaction swiss authorities
don't know how many
if any skiers broke the rules but the
story also raises questions as to why
any british people were going to
switzerland when
non-essential travel was being
discouraged
infection rates in the uk are highest
here in london and
in surrounding areas more than half of
new infections in this region are
thought to be from the new variant
of the virus and the health care system
is creaking
under the pressure the london ambulance
service said that boxing day was
one of its busiest days ever on monday
new daily infections in the uk passed 40
000
for the first time although that figure
includes data
from the three-day christmas weekend
just as it did with china
the world health organization is asking
for the uk not to be made a pariah
by other nations only if countries are
looking
and testing effectively will you be able
to pick up variants
and adjust strategies to cope
we must ensure that countries are not
punished for transparently sharing
new scientific findings but south korea
is extending its travel ban from the uk
after it joined the list of countries to
have found their first cases of the new
variant
and japan has now banned all
non-residents from traveling to the
country
until at least the end of january
redmond shannon double news
london south africa is now the latest
country to surpass
one million confirmed coveted 19 cases
and the grim milestone comes just nine
days after the country reported
900 000 cases officials say the second
wave surge is being fueled by school
holidays
public indifference and a different
potentially more infectious variant of
the virus
south africa is the worst hit country on
the continent
a chinese journalist has been sentenced
to four years in jail for her reporting
during the early stages
of the pandemic zhang zhen was convicted
of
picking corals and provoking trouble
the 37-year-old traveled to wuhan in
february to cover the coronavirus
outbreak
she posted on various social media
platforms zhang was arrested in may
and accused of spreading false
information she's believed to be the
first person to be tried and sentenced
for reporting on the virus her
first-hand accounts painted a more dire
picture of the situation
than the official narrative
a prominent women's rights activist with
ties to canada
has been sentenced to nearly six years
in jail in saudi arabia
lujan al-hatlul has been found guilty
under the country's broadly worded
counter-terrorism law the 31-year-old's
case and her imprisonment have sparked
criticism
all around the world and as ross lord
explains her supporters want the
canadian government
to intervene the actions that got
31-year-old
lujan alhat lul locked up in saudi
arabia
are things canadians consider basic
human rights
like driving a car and campaigning
against female oppression
al-hitlul is a graduate of the
university of british columbia
she lived in canada for five years she's
been in a saudi prison for two and a
half years
alleging she's been tortured now her
prison sentence of almost
six years has intensified international
outrage
what they have done is to now state to
the world
that they consider women's rights
activism to be an
act of terrorism her sister says
al-hatlul
cried when she heard the sentence she
says her sister will appeal
and ask for another investigation
regarding torture
as human rights activists call for al
hadlu's release
her former school ubc says it's written
to the canadian government to intervene
something her supporters suggest should
have been done long ago
in every type of negotiation between
governments
there is always a room to negotiate
human rights issues
and i believe that canada could play a
major role others
say canada's influence on the saudi
kingdom is limited
especially when al-hatlul is not a
canadian citizen
it's even a little more delicate right
now because our
diplomatic relations with the saudi
government are
not in a very good state of repair so
this is one where canada
is best off alloying itself with other
governments to denounce
these human rights abuses the united
nations human rights division
has posted the prison sentences deeply
troubling
the u.n says we understand early release
is possible and strongly encourage it as
a matter of urgency
there are reports the saudi court has
structured the prison sentence
so that al-hatlul could be released on
conditions
within months supporters hope that's the
case but they're reluctant to believe it
ross lord global news
late this afternoon global affairs
canada issued this statement
saying al-hatlul's conviction and
sentence is deeply
troubling it goes on to say canada
advocates for her
early release kovid 19
tightens its grip on the united states
coming up what doctors and nurses fear
as hospitals run at a room
plus secrets resurface
a little girl's diary discovered decades
later
the pandemic has hit the u.s hard
one in every 1 000 americans has died of
covid 19.
the staggering toll of more than 330
000 deaths is unmatched by any other
country
hospitals in some states are already
pushed beyond their limits
and as jackson proskow explains there
are fears that things
are going to get much worse california's
hospitals are in critical condition
overburdened with covid19 patients with
zero icu capacity left
the sick are being treated in parking
lots and cafeterias
it feels like we are working hard
every day trying to save lives and it's
just falling on deaf ears
we will take care of you we'll find
places we'll put you in hallways we'll
put you in conference rooms
the next step may be to start rationing
care based on who is most likely to
survive
we might be days away from that people
that are returning from the christmas
holiday
are going to start feeling ill in the
next few days
holiday travel risks creating a viral
wildfire
1.2 million travelers passed through u.s
airports on sunday alone
the highest number since the start of
the pandemic at a time when the virus is
everywhere
as we get into the next few weeks it
might actually get worse
december was the deadliest month of the
pandemic in the u.s
january could be even worse and there
are fears that a new more contagious
variant of the virus detected in the uk
is circulating unchecked on american
soil
i do think it's probably here we don't
know we're not monitoring for it in the
way that the uk
and other countries are all right here
we go all the while the great hope
a vaccine is rolling out much slower
than expected
the trump administration's operation
warp speed had promised to deliver 20
million doses by the end of 2020
three days before the new year and only
two million people have been vaccinated
there's no doubt about it that things
are going a little bit more slowly than
we want
too little too late for the thousands of
dead and for the severely ill
in san antonio texas covit 19 patient
james telschick
is now waiting for a double lung
transplant the disease will
keep trying to pull you in
and you just gotta you gotta keep
fighting
in this fight doctors warn the toughest
days are still to come
jackson prosco global news washington
ahead nearly 40 years later a secret
notebook is secret
no more but where is the young writer
now
the canadian press has named canadian
soccer captain christine sinclair as its
female athlete of the year
netting her second bobby rosenfeld award
the honor caps an all-time
record-breaking year for the two-time
olympic bronze medalist after she marked
186
overall international goals that is the
most of
any soccer player in the world a holiday
miracle this past weekend surrounding
the top secret diary of a 10 year old
girl
nick guns who happens to be a historian
found this notebook in the crawl space
of his parents toronto home
it came with a dire warning do not read
guns didn't he just flip through it for
a name and an age
turns out it belongs to a girl named
alison jenkins
in 1983 he posted a photo on social
media
and he found her jenkins is now a
singer-songwriter and a music teacher
living in vancouver
the week after christmas can be a little
bit of a anti-climax
and so to have something like this to
kind of keep me busy and keep me amused
it's been lovely
i mean just hundreds and hundreds of
people came online to
to take this on and help and and find a
person and that's just
so um so reassuring
the notebook will be mailed out to
vancouver tomorrow
next recognizing the everyday heroes
still
risking their safety to keep all of us
going
[Music]
2020 is the year thousands of people
perfected the wfh
experience working from home but when
you really think about it
that's a privilege essential workers
have to show up in person
to keep this country functioning keep us
fed
and keep us alive donna friesen reflects
on their role
in this pandemic so much of our humanity
rests
in our hands who we hold how we comfort
and how we use them for work among the
heroes of 2020 are those in the eye of
the storm
the doctors and nurses for them every
day is about life and death
it is as demanding and essential as it
gets
in those moments where there's high
stress you know
every family member just wants to be
there holding their hand and they can't
in the spring we began to salute them
using our hands
to applaud them for these heroes
getting up every day getting back in the
fight getting back to the front lines
comes at a great price it comes
with a personal sacrifice nevertheless
every day these brave men and women
show up and it dawned on us health care
workers
aren't the only ones using their hands
to help us
if you're working in the grocery store
during the pandemic i want you to know
you're making a real difference i'm sure
it hasn't always been easy for you
but your work is essential thousands of
others are doing essential work too
when we hoarded food they kept the
shelves stocked
kept the checkout lines moving thousands
of people doing work that isn't
glamorous or well paid
risking their own health to serve us and
help us
our social workers transition house
staff
our home care workers and all those
trying to assist
people in need when you're out on the
street rescuing
women or children or feeding the hungry
or providing support to the disabled
community
a lot of their work is still face to
face
and they are still showing up every day
showing up to care feed and comfort our
elders and care homes
to deliver our packages drive the buses
collect our garbage teach our children
all of it hands-on work that keeps our
world in motion
and integrates so seamlessly into our
modern lives
we tend to take it for granted i hope
that one of the things
that this pandemic has taught us
is that people who do some of the work
which is
most essential for our actual
our literal survival are among
the lowest paid people in our country
it is a question of value to quote oscar
wilde
do we know the price of everything and
the value of nothing
when this coveted crisis is over there
are deeper questions to tackle
about the worth of heartfelt hands-on
work
for now what we offer those doing
essential exhausting work is profound
gratitude
donna friesen global news
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm farah nasser
tonight's york canada is peachland
british columbia thank you so much for
watching take care of yourselves
and each other have a good night